[Musique]
et
ça tue
que là bas
[Musique]
parfois ce sont les rivières sont en
crue
joie j'ai grandit donc en martinique est
déjà dans au collège 22 puis le collège
au lycée ont avec les copains on
reprenait les tubes de deux trémies dass
die ty de porto rico et la bossa nova de
poésie tout ce à quoi donc on a moi j'ai
grandi comme ça avec un jointures ces
musiques là mais moi je veux qu'il n'en
a pas l'air je suis pétri de toutes ces
musiques là ma musique csmc musique en
en création aussi un devenir 14
[Musique]
c'est vraiment
je sais pas faire
la distinction entre le reggae le combat
l'appui qui le
pourquoi
donc à ckoi
pour moi dans ma tête tout ça si vous
libérer la partie
le métissage c'est ce qu'on aime comme
dans nos régions nous sommes la
possibilité entre l'afrique et
l'occident nous sommes créatifs
isométrique de doute et en même temps de
création c'est l'ordinaire prochain sans
même chercher moins calmes à la déchire
- bakary koné
[Musique]